the NFL game start I have two special
guests with me the name is Aron Seely so
you guys are standing here in line are
you betting today you're not gonna bet
today not today
okay let's talk hypothetical if you work
in a bit who would you bet on and how
much would you bet
I tell you that Kansas City Tennessee
that's a good one I love you that's it
Mary yeah you got to take that bit up
higher okay
hypothetical if you were betting today
how much in what team copier hundred
dollars but I would use the same thing
yes I love Jill and Michael Thomas there
you have it they told you what they've
been on they're not betting you see the
difference between the women and the men
administering them with the money and
the wives are saving that's why I'm not
married anymore
ladies thank you tell your husband's I
say good luck today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
we have two contenders for play of the
year in the NFL a TD pass for punter - a
kicker in Miami and a double reverse
with an option to deshaun Watson for a
touchdown this right here will put you
in contention to hit those weekly wagers
we know the VR betting show presented by
Caesars Palace sports book on County
Richards and this is our MVP and getting
insider Kelly baby Yoda Stewart and then
your slightly taller than baby Oda but
more importantly knowledge Rick barely
cabbie when Miami is no longer taking
four - or Joe Perot or even chase young
we really are in a galaxy far far away
the force is strong with my best bets 10
2 and 1 on the season my week 14 picks
coming right up let's get to those
marquee matchups
[Music]
first up we have the cheese plus 3 at
the Patriots total forty nine and a half
I've been preaching this all year you do
not bet against Brady and Belichick in
Foxborough if you like the Chiefs you
just stay away why because the Pats
16 and 5 against the spread their last
21 home games while my drive to work
this morning every single talking head
every single station Brady's done
Brady's done the Patriots are done the
Patriots are done
I like the Patriots minus three I think
that Brady takes advantage of that week
Chiefs secondary today 49ers plus two at
the Saints total 44 and a half this game
kind of has me in a glass case of
emotion the Niners have made me so much
money the last couple of weeks and I
want to back them here big money is
coming in on a brama alone on an island
I think the Saints get the win here and
the cover nine two and one straight up
eight and two against the spread in
their last 10 games the Superdome is a
tough place to play this one's for NFC
bragging rights I like the Saints -2 and
I don't know if the Niners are gonna be
able to sell this guy behind me mr.
Michael Thomas speaking of all-pro
receivers we have one of our own here to
help us break down the game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's good to be back it's great to see
you sometimes I don't want to leave you
sure you're you're one of our favorite
Pete Miller and I know that as he
watchful yeah some of your favorite
people I love moving chai tell us about
how rookie Devo Samuel has impressed you
this season very impressive
there's always the learning curve when
it comes to working receivers coming to
in that bill having to adapt to the game
the speed playing a plan against grown
men he's been consistent all year round
despite the injuries that they've had to
the receiving poor now on the other side
of the ball what do you make of this man
Michael Thomas's skill set what are your
favorite to aasaiya Messiah the Messiah
the past four years he's been consistent
ever since he stepped in the met in the
Superdome the woodies done withdrew
reason at all from this man is Shaun
paints been unbelievable he's leading
NFL and receiving yards I believe in and
catches he just the best in the game
there's a reason why he's worth that 100
million dollar contract yes he's earning
and watching Michael Thomas go to work
every week has been an absolute joy in
watching football with you Chad and
Kelly's been amazing because I learned
so many nuggets about the game this
matchup in the Superdome in a few
moments will be awesome okay let's get
to the rest of your marquee matchup
shall we
absolutely Gabby
Ravens minus six and a half of the Bills
total of 44 I know I'm bettin against
Baltimore again and why because the
Ravens are overvalued
yes Lamar Jackson is going to win MVP
and yes he's probably gonna win this
game but I'm taking the better defense
here with the points this one's gonna be
closer than indicated I like the bills
plus six and a half the Seahawks
down to a pick'em here at Caesar's
Palace versus the Rams to Sunday night
game total forty seven and a half be
looking at those prime time unders
because they keep cashing by the way
these two teams have split the last 16
head-to-head matchups I have a best bet
on this one but you got to wait to the
end of the show here's a quick recap of
my marquee matchups this week I like the
Pats Saints in the bills and again we
have a best bet coming up and the
Seahawks Rams game against the spread
there are more ways to bet on the game
than just aside in the total and this
week's expert analysis Chad Jeff
Ratcliffe of pro Football Focus shares
advice on how to find value in another
popular wager that's the profiteering
grades of Cub now right world sports
betting first and foremost I think you
need to get yourself a good set of
projections or a lot of sites out there
who offer projections for players so you
can you can get those then compare those
to the line but it's not just about the
line it's also about the odds right -
150 is a lot different than plus 115 so
look up implied probability do yourself
that favor and learn how to calculate
the implied probability of those odds
factors that into the line and now you
have your way of spotting a good bet
additionally the over is often not the
best play the under send to hit more
often than the overs yet betters love
betting overs they want to bet the over
they want to bet the favorite and that's
a psychological thing that sports books
certainly do know now in NBA it's a
little bit different for NBA player prop
an NFL player props look into the under
that'll help you out over
long term but how do you spot the bets
that you should be playing well if I'm
looking at individual positions
quarterbacks offers the least value all
the position for betting purposes and
really we're looking at some basic stats
here that we're gonna be playing props
on passing yards tend to be the tightest
lines of any lines out there there's
very little edge on both lines most
weeks with most quarterbacks so I tend
to make very few plays on passing yards
there's a lot more value in receptions
receiving yards and rushing yards thanks
to Jeff for the tips you can find them
on twitter at jeff Radcliffe everybody
loves profits and here at Caesars they
are offering the following profits for
tonight's Seahawks and Rams matchups
before we get to your selected your
pitch Cooper [ __ ] receiver watching this
man go to work what impresses you about
him
the fact that he's only in his fourth
year he's been extremely consistent
coming off of ACL tear and still being
productive
despite the up-and-down quarterback play
phenomenal and dude is almost hit a
thousand yards already and then across
Amina just maybe across the line of
scrimmage his teammate Robert woods
Robert woods but him USC dude okay la do
monster game last week against the
cardinal huge horrible horrible
secondary 13 catches 172 yards I'm not
gonna expect a monster day out of him
playing against that Seahawks defense
which is ranked 13th against the payers
so okay so we're looking at these prop
bets we have Cooper Cup over over city
over a build a bridge and get over it
okay and then Robert woods 68.5 I don't
know I don't know I got the I got the on
the long I got thundering woods okay you
listen Eddie Eddie divisional baton to
little matchups are usually usually
great but when Russell Wilson is at the
helm no lead is safe especially on the
road in LA but this kind of place to
Jared Goff a little bit more Kelly what
do you make of these receiver frogs
I think Chad is absolutely spot-on my
dad would always over here giving great
wide receivers in sight all right guys
let's take a look at my card for
14 all right we're gonna start off
Monday night so called the J plus nine
and a half at the Eagles total forty
five and a half or go a line Manning's
back what they've been doing the last
nine weeks I'm not so sure I hope he's
been practicing but Eagles on the flip
side you want to lay nine and out points
of this team that just hit rock bottom
they just lost to the Miami Dolphins
don't overreact either way I'm not
touching either these sides I think this
game is gonna be an absolute snooze fest
we're going under forty five and a half
or in a catch some more of those prime
time unders the Titans minus three at
the Raiders total forty seven and a half
this is absolutely a bi-lo situation
here on the right
Raiders they have now lost two straight
but you know what they do do well six
and one against the spread in their last
seven as a home dog Titans a little
overvalued after last week I like the
Raiders plus three the Steeler is minus
two and a half at the Cardinals total
forty three and a half this one's come
down for the opening number of three and
why because the initial line move was
not warranted to begin with but look at
line here with Steelers pickup the
Steelers do their job and beat up as a
home dog their divisional rival in the
Browns the Cardinals got the brick speed
off of them by the LA Rams but Tomlin
has a home dog is not equal to Tommen as
a road favorite Pittsburgh no James
Connor no juju I like the Cardinals plus
two and that is my card for week 14
cabbie I'm hoping to hear one of those
signature Mike Tomlin phrases in the
press conference afterwards / well I
wanna wait for that question to be
answered after the Steelers game here
are some questions from our audience in
minds of the public the first one is why
do you advise against teasing over
Kelly okay so we've talked about this on
the show before we've got two teen
six-point teasers now when you are
betting teasers you need to hit over 70
percent of the time just to break even
because you're laying a dollar 20 if not
even more we've talked about the key
numbers of three and seven for the 80s
but as regards the totals
there's a couple other numbers they just
aren't as valuable as those key numbers
of three and seven this week we have a
perfect teaser situation and that is
getting the Raiders plus nine and the
Cardinals plus eight the gut wins 24/7
wants to know when you're handicapping
NFL games are you strictly a numbers
person or do you include your own
personal I test your selections so the
math on NFL is the tightest out of any
sport the bookmakers spend so much time
on this why because that long line here
at Caesar's Palace people can't wait to
bet the NFL so they do their best work
on it now regards to how I break it down
from there sure you're looking at
situations you're looking at motivation
you're looking at matchups you're
looking at coaching so of course all
those things are all-encompassing of the
high test Kelly's best bets always pass
this eye test because she studies the
math she's 10 to a 1 this season - Kelly
you know what time it is give the people
what they want
all right guys we cash back-to-back
weeks by backing the 49ers improving our
season record at 10 2 & 1 this year and
I can't make it a three-peat but I am
gonna stick to the NFC West we're gonna
back the LA Rams tonight
yeah Twitter I know how can i how can I
feed Russell Wilson in primetime oh how
dare me well I'm doing it twice in one
week
Seattle 2 & 5 against a spread in their
last seven games versus LA the Rams
showed me last week versus the Cardinals
they have not given up on their seasons
they will play a divisional opponent
tough so I'm back in the Rams out of
pick I'm here at Caesar's Palace let's
recap all of my picks for week 14 these
are listed in order of confidence on how
many units I brought I'd recommend you
bet on each I've got a forty to play on
the Rams three units on the Patriot
Saints and Bill's we also have two units
on the Giants Eagles under the Raiders
the Cardinals and not to forget that
six-point teaser on Oakland and Arizona
Steve Belichick was introduced to the
internet that season glorious mullet in
all do you bring your first football
show or one of your first football shows
that he asked you to do yeah I got a
couple miles between me he's about to
enter 2020 with in 1987 haircut Chad is
that mullet the Patriot when the mothers
not to pay away but the answers he just
gave was I think that's the Belichick if
there's a barbershop in every of the 32
locker rooms and out in it and he's a
safeties coaching guns a rambunctious
squad that'll be brutally honest with
you yeah how was he getting away with
the mullet Jesse because the players in
embracing something that the NFL allows
now individualism see you little fool
you or you're about a decade before you
it was frowned upon when I was playing
but now it's just there you wish you
could get all up those fines back like
you know what we NFL League office I'm
sure you're gonna see this please that's
at least a mil 5 that you
at least Izzy get on that please New
York
thank you for streaming the be our
bedding show on the Bleacher Report app
YouTube and Twitter it has been
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
book and thank you to our favorite
all-pro future hall-of-famer expert mr.
Joe Johnson it's always great having you
with us
be sure to follow along on social @br
Otis for Benny's for all microc good
luck on your bets
let's have a great week call me if you
need me
[Music]